[موسيقى]
اعادت ازمه الصراع المشتعله حاليا في
السودان بين الشريكين العسكريين رئيس
المجلس السيادي السوداني البرهان ونائبه
حمدتي قائد قوات الدعم السريع المكون من
عناصر مسلحه اطلق عليها جنجويد اقليم
دارفور الى الواجهه مره اخرى
وبحث قضيه الحرب الدارفوريه التي احتدمت
في العام 2003 واكثر ما كتب عن هذه الحرب
خبريا وتحليليا لم يتجاوز الابعاد ودوافع
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه اثنيه وعرقيه او
مطالب الاقليم في التمثيل السياسي مع ذلك
ورغم الروايه الشائعه عن حرب دارفور فلا
يمكن التغافل عن ان اوجه نوبات الصراع في
الاقليم جاءت بعد المفاصله بين
الانقلابيين على حكم الرئيس المنتخب
الصادق المهدي التي تمت بين معسكر حسن
الترابي الامين السابق للجبهه الاسلاميه
القوميه والمؤتمر الوطني والمعسكر الاخر
بقياده المشير عمر البشير القائد العسكري
ورئيس جمهوريه السودان
تاكيد هذه الروايه الاخرى ياتي من داخل
الحركه الاسلاميه ذاتها التي اكدت ان
اشتعال الصراع كان بمثابه تصفيه حسابات
بين جناحي لحركه الاسلاميه السودانيه
نفسها اي ترابي والبشير وان ما حدث بالفعل
بحسب محمد الشنقيطي احد اعلاميه تيار
الاصول وباحثي انه وبعد ان حل البشير
البرلمان عام
1999 واعلن حاله الطوارئ ووضع شيخه ترابي
في السجن كان ميلاد محنه دارفور بشكلها
الكارثي واوضح الشنقيطي اكثر وقال
فباعتباري ان اهل دارفور من الاسلاميين
المشاركين في الحركه الاسلاميه ومن بينهم
قاده التمرد المنظمين للجبهه الاسلاميه
القوميه التي يقودها
الذين علقوا امالا عريضه على ثوره الانقاذ
برفع الضيم عن اقليمهم جاءت خيبه امل
جديده تسبب ذلك بتمرد ضباط الاسلاميين
المنحدرين من دارفور بتشجيع من التراب
بعدما فصلهم البشير وعلي عثمان فسلح
البشير قبائل البدو من اهل دارفور لمواجهه
التمرد التي عرفت بقوات الجنجويد
وبالمقابل ولدت حركه العدل والمساواه
المواليه للترابي على ايدي عسكريين في
جبهه الانقاذ والحركه الاسلاميه فهل يمكن
فصل مشكله دارفور عن مشكله الحركه
الاسلاميه السودانيه نفسها وهل قضيه
دارفور مساله اقتصاديه واجتماعيه اثنيه
قبليه ام هناك من استحث ووظف المشكلات
الكامنه وما تعريف قوات الجنجويد فهل فعلا
تعني قطاع الطرق والسارقين انا هدى الصالح
وهذا برنامج جماعات مناقشه بحث قضيه
دارفور والحرب الاهليه التي قامت فيها
التي اكلت الاخضر واليابس فشردت وهجرت
مئات الالاف وسقط المئات من القتلى
والضحايا يشارك معنا من الولايات المتحده
الدكتور الباقر عفيف مدير مركز الخاتم
عدلان للاستناره والتنميه البشريه وكتب في
مجال الدراسات الاجتماعيه وعن ازمه الهويه
والحكم في السودان صار عضوا فاعلا في
تنظيم الاخوان الجمهوريين الذي اسسه
الاستاذ محمود محمد طه كان مسؤول اقليمي
للحملات بمنطقه الشرق الاوسط بالامانه
الدوليه لمنظمه العفو الدوليه بلندن
وخبيرا بمعهد السلام الامريكي ومن مؤلفاته
ما وراء دارفور الهويه والحرب الاهليه في
السودان حياك الله معنا دكتور اهلا يا
مرحب بك يا استاذ هدى في البدايه حدثنا عن
هويه اقليم دارفور وخلفياتها الاجتماعيه
والقبليه والدينيه
وايضا عن المكون العربي في هذا الاقليم
كبير جدا وعنده تاريخ عريق خالص
يعني كان في مملكه
وصلتنا في دارفور استمرت قرون وهي احدث
واخر السلطنات التي
سقطت في السودان اللي سقطت في العام 1916
بعد ان غزا القوات
[موسيقى]
التركيه البريطانيه
السودان
للمره
وانهاء حكم المهديه
الظل لمده 16 عام او نحو السلطان قائمه
الى ان سقطت في ذلك العام 1916
اقليم يتكون من مجموعات
سكانيه
لو حددناها من طابعها
المعيشي
بنلقاها تنقسم ما بين
زراع مستقرين في الوديان والاراضي الخصبه
ورعاه متحركين في المناطق الشماليه من
دارفور يخطون
يعني مجموعات سكانيه تنقسم الى جسمين كبار
يعني هم يصنفوا انفسهم بهذه الطريقه
قبائل عربيه او ذات قصور عربيه
وقبائل اخرى مجموعات سكانيه اصيله او
اصليه
ظلت في هذه الارض لالاف السنين وهي
تصنف نفسها بان مجموعات تنتمي الى السودان
والى افريقيا
ولا تعرف نفسها باي جذور خارج حدود
السودان الحاليه
القبائل العربيه الهجرات العربيه
كانت متاخره نوعا ما اعتقد بدات منذ القرن
17 واستمرت
بشكل متصل
والمجموعات السكانيه زي ما قلنا هي رعاه
ومزارعين وظلت على طول الوقت تكون هناك
احتكاكات
ما بين الرعاه
والمزارعين المعروفه دائما بتعديات الرعاه
على مزارع
المزارعين عندما اما يعني يكون هنالك محل
او تكون هنالك
ضيق في المراعي
فتنشا احتكاكات عاده يستخدم فيها السلاح
التقليدي من السيوف والحراب والعصي
والخلافه
وتنشر وهناك كانت على طول المدى
اليات محليه لحل النزاعات
الاليات المحليه تسمى الجوديه اللي هو
دائما بيجي طرف ثالث من الحكماء
وينزع فتيل الازمه يوقف الحرب والحرب
دائما لانها بتستخدم فيها الاساليب
الاسلحه التقليديه ما بتنتج عنها
مااسف ضخمه يعني يعني يتحاربون اليوم كله
ويكون القتلى افراد والجرحى افراد
والنظام الجوديه
بينبني على المصالحات والديه دائما ويحصر
الخسائر وتستطيع
القبيله المعتديه التي فرضت عليها الديه
ان تدفع هذه الديه فكل النظام الاهلي يعني
متسق بمعنى انه
الطبيعه متصغ مع طبيعه الاسلحه
المستخدمه متسخه مع عدد الضحايا متسع متسق
مع القدرات الاقتصاديه للقبيله في انها
دائما قادره على دفع الديات والغرامات
وتعود الحياه الى سيرتها الاولى
وتستمر بهذه الطريقه ايش ابرز
القبائل ابرز القبائل العربيه هو قبائل
البقاره او الريزيقات يسمونهم
ودي قبائل كبيره جدا يعني في داخلها تنضم
بطون كثيره جدا هذه قب العربيه دي القبائل
العربيه اما القبائل الافريقيه هناك ثلاثه
مجموعات كبيره اللي هي الفور
ومجموعات الفور هي التي تسمى بها الاقليم
دارفور اللي هي الدائره التي يقطنها
ويسيطر عليها ويحكمها الفور
وهناك قبائل المساليد والمساليد ايضا يعني
مجموعه كبيره كانت عندهم سلطنه قائمه
بذاتها دائما تحتل الجزء الغربي من دارفور
مع الحدود مع تشاد
وهناك قبائل الزغاوه
قبائل الزغاوه عند امتدادات داخل الحدود
التشاديه والقبائل العربيه نفسها عند
امتدادات داخل الحدود التشاديه وعند
امتدادات في النيجر وبعض الدول الافريقيه
فمن هنا جاء مساله التداخل وحركه الرعاه
والرعاه طبعا لا يعرفون الحدود انما
يتابعون
حيوانات حسب طبيعه
الطبيعه يعني من
متابعه الكلى والماء زي ما يقال عاده يعني
طبعا في يعني لو بايجاز هناك ايضا جوانب
السياسيه يعني الاقليم يعني منذ
الخمسينيات وايضا في الثمانينات كان هناك
مطالب بحقوق الاقليم السياسيات تمثيل
السياسي في الحكومه صحيح نعم الاقليم في
الحقيقه ظل ملحقا
ودوله بالدوله وسط السودان وطبعا هي دي اس
اس المشكله انه نحن نظامنا نظام الحكم منذ
الاستعمار
وحتى الاستقلال ظل على
وتيره واحده من كونه الطبقه الحاكمه دائما
كانت تستمد من الشريط النيلي
للمجموعات الساكنه على الشريطه وهي
مجموعات في الاصل نوبيه لكنها اعربت
واتخذت لها
اصول عربيه خارج
لذلك نجد انه
كل
المجموعات دي تنتسب الى
اصول الى الى شبه الجزيره العربيه
واصبحت تنظر الى نفسها هذه المجموعات
الحاكمه النوبيه المستعربه تنظر الى نفسها
كمجموعات عربيه
وظلت يعني ثقافيا منتميه الى العالم
العربي
وهي التي ورثت السلطه من
المستعمر الانجليزي
ومشت على نهجه في عدم الاعتراف
بالسودان كبلد متنوع ومتعدد الثقافات
وكانت هذه الدوله المركزيه وهذه المجموعه
المهيمنه يعني
نشرت نفسها في باقي السودان على اعتبار
انه الحقت المجموعات الاخرى بها كان عندها
مشروع كبير جدا اسمه المشروع الاسلم
والتعريب نحن نعلم ان السودان القديم قبل
ان يفصل منه الجنوب هو بلد يعني عدد
المسلمين فيهم
يعني يمكن يمثل في احسن الحالات 50% من
السكان
وهناك احصاءات
تجعل عدد المسلمين
يعني لما جاء رحل الاستعمار
بنسبه 40%
او نحو ذلك في طبعا المسيحيين وفي الاغلب
الاخرين الذين لا ينتمون الى الاسلام او
المسيحيه ينتمون الى الاديان الروحانيه
الافريقيه التقليديه
وحتى الاسلام في السودان
اسلام مختلط بالثقافه المحليه لانه جاء عن
طريق التطور الوحيد ولم يجيء عن طريق
الفتح بالقوه
ولذلك ابتسم
بالسمات المحليه لذلك هناك كان في اسلام
طابعه خاص في دارفور واسلام طابعه خاص في
شرق السودان واسلام طابعه خاص في وسط
السوداني كنت بسالك بسه وتكمل حديثك
كلها طرق صوفيا الاسلام دخل الى السودان
عن طريق المتصوفه
والطريقه القادريه هي من الطرق الكبرى
دخلت السودان والطريقه التجانيه جات من
غرب السودان عن طريق من موروكو عن طريق
غرب السودان وموريتانيا الى جاءت في
دارفور لذلك نجد عنده وجود معتبر في
دارفور لكن
البلد كلها دخل الاسلام عن طريق
التصوفه معروفين
بسماحه
بقبول للاخر بعدم
باتجاههم نحو الهدايه اكثر من نحو العقاب
او الاداري لذلك الناس احبوا قاده التصوف
والتفوا حولهم واصبحوا مجموعات يعني تلتف
حولهم وتتعلم منهم ولانهم عاشوا نفس
عيشتهم ولبسوا لبسهم
وسكنوا مثل بيوتهم وتحدثوا لغتهم الد ارجه
وحل لهم مشاكلهم لذلك انتشرت بشكل كبير
جدا حتى لا تكون لا يمكن ان تجد اسره في
السودان الا وهي منتميه الى واحده من
الطرق الصوفيه قشطه ايش قصد طيب في طرق
التدين اللي تختلف باقليم دارفور عن باقي
المناطق لو بايجاز هي بس مساله
العادات الاجتماعيه الموجوده في دارفور
طرق كسب العيش طرق
الغذاء مثلا
الاشياء دي دائما تختلف في دارفور عن
[موسيقى]
لعله اكبر مثال يعني بيؤخذ هي مساله
التعامل مع المشروبات الكحوليه
لانه اجزاء كبيره جدا من السودان القديم
تعتبر المشروبات الكحوليه الخفيفه
عند يعني دائما نسبه كحول
متدنيه زي 4% او 5% ما يسمى عندنا اسماء
كثيره لكن في كل اقليم عندها اسم مثلا
مريسه تعرف باسم المريسه في دارفور وتعرف
باسم البدنيه مثلا في في شمال السودان
وتعرف باسماء اخرى في في
غاليم السودان المختلفه مثلا المشروبات
ديه عاديه ان يعني تشرب وهي تصنف في في
المدارس الفقهيه الصارمه كانها خمر
وانها محرمه التداول فيها وشربها والتعامل
بها او كذا لكن هذا هو ليس الحال مثلا في
السودان برضو هناك عادات اجتماعيه كثيره
جدا منها علاقه الرجل بالمراه منها
طرق كسب العيش وعمل المراه في خارج المنزل
وكلها
يعني لو وزناها بالمعيار الصارم
العيار الفقهي نجد اننا مقبوله اسلاميا
لكن في المدارس في هذه المناطق ميده
مقبوله جدا ومن العرف
المقبول من الجميع يعني بدون منظر اليه
نظره مريبه
طيب استاذي بعد هذه النبذه عن الاقليم
ابغى اسالك
ملابسات الازمه ازمه دارفور بتحديدا 2003
احنا نعرف كان هناك ازمات لكن كان يعني
اوجهها كان في هذا العام 2003 البعض بيشوف
ان هي كانت يعني صراع سياسي ما بين البشير
وبين حركات ثائره تطالب بحقوق اجتماعيه
واقتصاديه وهناك وصف اخر بانها حرب كانت
بهدف التطهير
العرقيشي الصحيح في يعني في هالموضوع هذا
يعني هي ما ذكرتيه
يعتبر اما نتائج ثانويه للحرب او
او يعني اسباب
اقصد اما نتائج للحرب او اسباب
ثانويه للحرب
حقيقه الامر انه دارفور
انه هناك علاقات حكم مختله في السودان نحن
عندنا ازمه حب في السودان
ازمه الحكم ممكن الخصها في كلمات
اولا السودان بلد متعدده الثقافات متعدده
الاعراق متعدد الاديان متعدد اللغات
ومتعدد الطبيعه المناخات
وهذه التعدديه
لم تجد تعبيرها في الحكم
الحكم اذا نظرنا الى الحكم كانه الحكم
الصالح
كانما هو مراه تعكس المجتمع كله
بنفترض انه كل
السكاني معبر عنهم
مؤسسيا ودستوريا وقانونيا
وهناك علاقات فرص متساويه في الحكم لكن
بكل اسف ده ما كان الحال انه
هذه التعدديه لم تكن منعكسه
عند الحكم نفسه
الحكم كان حكم احادي النظره وكان لا يقبل
من الاخرين ان يكونوا اخرين
كانوا يريد للاخرين ان يغيروا هوياتهم
ويتنازلوا عنها لصالح ان يصبحوا
متماهين مع هويه الطبقه الحاكمه
وكذلك ده عنده انعكاس انعكاسات من النحل
الاقتصاديه لم يكن هناك امنيه كافيه لم
تكن هناك مساواه كافيه لم يكن هناك توزيع
للخدمات ما بين المركز
والمحيط حق المركزه والهامش اي
خدمات متساويه كان هناك ظلم كبير جدا جدا
للهامش فعندنا طبقه حاكمه همشه باقي
السودان كله
وهيات لنفسها فقط وحتى ما هياته لنفسها
ولمحيطها الجغرافي ولحاضنتها الاجتماعيه
لم تبلغ فيه نفسه مبلغا
عظيما لكن قدري ما استطاعت ان تفعلوا هذه
الطبقه الحاكمه من تنميه ومن تقديم
للخدمات ومن فتح فرص العمل كان في محيطها
في وسط السودان فقط وحسب لذلك
الاليم كانت تحتج وكانت تحتاج احتجاج سلمي
حركه دارفور هناك حركه اسمها حركه نهض
الباركور نهضه دارفور حركه سياسيه تاسست
في الخمسينات وكانت او الستينات
اعلى اعلم بالدقه
تاسست وتطالب سلميا بان ينصف الاقليم
اقليم دارفور من حيث التنميه حتى طلباتها
كانت تتعدى الاعتراف الثقافي ولا كانت
تحتوي على الاعتراف باللغات او الاشياء
هذه كانوا عايزين ببساطه تنميه
وحسب صحيح بس دكتور علشان ما يداهمنا
الوقت لان عندي محاور كتابه انا ودي لو
ندخل في
اطار
مثل ما تفضلت حضرتك ان
المطالب الحقوقيه في الاقليم من سكان
الاقليم كانت منذ وقت مبكر من الخمسينيات
وكانت بشكل سلمي يعني في ال85 حدثت هناك
بعض الاحداث لكن
الحرب الاهليه التي كان اخذت صدى كبير حتى
دوليا وعالميا
مشردت المئات مئات الالاف من السكان وسقط
العديد من الضحايا فيها
شل كان الاسباب الجوهريه فيها هل هي
المطالب الحقوقيه او انه مثل ما قلت حضرتك
كانت اسباب الثانويه
الاسباب الجوهريه فيها اسباب الجوهريه هي
الظلم
الواقع وعدم الاعتراف
بالخصائص حقت الاقليم وعدم وعدم يعني
ايصال الخدمات التنمويه للاقليم ده السبب
الاساسي
جنوب السودان كان في حاله حرب
لمده 50 عام
وفي عام 2,02 بدات
الحكومه
حكومه البشير تتفاوض مع حركه تحرير
السودان بقياده الدكتور جون جراند
وواضح انه ماشيين عشان ما يدق الجنوب حقه
الرساله دي
المفاوضات مع مع الحركه حركه تحرير
السودان في الجنوب ارسلت رساله
واضحه لاهل دارفور وبقيه الاقاليم من انه
اذا طالبت سلميا بحقوقك لن تجدها بدليل
انهم ظلوا يطالبوا منذ الخمسينات بحقوق
سلميه وحتى العام 200 الف جنيه ولم يجدوه
اي حقوق في حين ان الجنوب كان يحمل السلاح
فاجبر الحكومه انها تعطيه حقوقه وتعترف
بها في العام 200 الف واثنين بعد حروبات
داميه
سواء الرساله اللي وصلت لجنوب لاهل دارفور
انه اذا لم تحمل السلاح سوف لن تجده حقوق
لذلك
بدات بداوا الاعداد لحمل السلاح واول حركه
في الحقيقه
حملت السلاح ما كانت حركه العدل والمساواه
انما كانت حركه تحرير السوداني
بقياده عبد الواحد النور ذيل البدءوا في
عام 200 الف وثلاثه لحقتهم بعد ذلك
حركه العدل والمساواه
وحركه الجناح السياسي طبعا لحسن الترابي
كما هو قبل ما ندخل في صلب هذا الموضوع
بخصوص حركه العدوى المساواه اللي مثل ما
وصفتها حضرتك انها الجناح السياسي
للترابي ابغى نسمع مع بعض مقطع
الباحث والاعلامي محمد الشنقيطي الله
يسلمك
واسماء تعليقك على هالموضوع
حينما انفصل التراب البشير انضم اغلب
ابناء الحركه الاسلاميه في المنطقه
الغربيه من السودان الى صف التراب يعني من
ابناء دارفور وكردفان المناطق الغربيه من
السودان
وظل
الشمال والشرق مع البشير فاصبح الخلافه
ليس خلافا سياسيا وانما خلاف اقليمي وقد
ري وحينما حدث هذا
ذهب البشير واصحابه الى تصفيه الحركه من
ابناء المنطقه الغربيه
لماذا لولائهم للبشر وخصوصا العسكريين اول
ما فعله البشير بعد ان نختلف مع الترابي
هو انه
هو الجيش من ابناء دارفور وابناء كردفان
ابناء المحافظات الغربيه الولايات الغربيه
خوفا من ان ولائهم بالتراب قد يساعدهم على
الانقلاب على البشير وطبعا الترابي ما
عنده مشكله ان يكرر
لكن ماذا حدث هؤلاء الضباط
وهم من ابناء الحركه الاسلاميه من المنطقه
الغربيه الذين
اخرجهم طلدهم البشير من
الجيل تحولوا الى نواه التمرد
كثير من الناس يغيبوا عنهم يظن ان قضيب
دارفور هي مجرد صراع بين الرعاه
والاهل الحضر الرعاه البدو
من القصور الافريقيه او انه الصراع مناطقي
لكن هو حقيقه نوته
الصراع داخل الحركه الاسلاميه
قادر الى الحرب كان له دور كبير
الحرب لان الضباط حركه الاسلاميه الذين
طردهم البشير من الجيش خوفا من ولائهم
للتراب هم الذين بداوا
تمتزج هنا الانشطار الحركي مع الحساسيات
الاجتماعيه التقليديه في السودان كانت حرب
دارفور العشريه الثانيه من حكم الانقاذ
فيها امران اساسيان طبعها
من شيطان الحركه الاسلاميه
وانشطار السوداني بحرب والحرب مصيبه
مات فيها عشرات الالاف وشرد مئات الالوف
وانتهجت كل
الحرمه طيب استاذ مثل ما سمنا مع بعض حديث
الباحث محمد الشنقيطي بهالموضوع وبرجع معك
بان مؤسس حركه العدوى المساواه وايضا هو
طبعا استقال بعد المفاصل وقعت في الجبهه
الاسلاميه ما بين الترابي والبشير في عام
1999 وخرج من السودان وكانوا عضو في
الجبهه القومي الجبهه الاسلاميه القوميه
اللي كانت تمسك مفاصل يعني السلطه في
حكومه الانقاذ الوطني وايضا تقلد مناصب
وزاريه في ذلك الوقت كذلك عندنا حركه
تحرير السوداني يعني من خلال اطلاع اجريته
على هالموضوع كان ايضا انها في يعني في
نفس التاريخ عام 99 بدات تنشط سياسيا ومن
ثم 2001 بدات تعلن عن نفسها ويعني
خرجت اكثر على السطح مثلها مثل عدو
المساواه حتى بدايه تدشين الاعمال الامنيه
ضد
القوات العسكريه للبشير نعم يعني مثل ما
سلفت القول انه حركه تحرير السودان بقياده
عبد الواحد النور هي الحركه اللي بدات
وهي ايضا الحركه حتى اسمها كان يعني
يقتدي
بحركه
الحركه الشعبيه لتحرير السودان
هي تتلمزت في الحقيقه على هذه الحركه
وتبنت اطروحاتها اطروحات السودان الجديد
وسمت نفسها حركه تحرير السوداني
واضح جدا كان يعني قادته بالذات الاستاذ
عبد الواحد النور هو من المعجبين جدا
ويعتبر نفسه على الدكتور جون
وهذه يؤكد الربط ما بين حركه الحركه
الشعبيه لتحرير السوداني الجنوبيه
وحركه تحرير السودان الدارفوريه
يعني وده المبعثه الاساسي زي ما قلت لك
الرساله التي ارسلها البشير والتراب وخلاف
للاقاليم انه اذا لم تكن عندك قوه لا ما
عندك صور وما عندك حق لذلك هم مشوا عشان
ينشروا هذه القوه
وهاجموا اول هجوم كان على مطار الفاشر
وعلى حاميه المباشر
وكان هجوم مباغت ودمروا الحاميه واعتقلوا
قائده
يعني كانت ضربه كبيره دي كانت تدشين
الحركه
وبدات بعد ذلك طبعا الهجمه المضاده من
الحكومه للقضاء على الحركه
ده ادى
لابرز نتيجتين
النتيجه الاولى انه بدا بدات الماسي في
دارفور لانه البشير ببساطه شديده جدا اراد
ان يعاقب
القبائل التي خرج ابنائها في ما يسمى
بالتمرد الذي تمردت على على الدوله التي
كانت
معك مع الترابي وايضا ضباط لسه يعني احنا
بنتكلم عن حركه تحرير السودان قبل ان تظهر
حركه العدل والمساواه في السطح
جاءت بعد حركه العدل والمساء حركه العدو
والمساويه في حقيقه الامر هي التعبير اللي
ما بيربط انا شخصيا لا اربط حركه العدل او
المساواه باي قضيه تخص دارفور على الاطلاق
ان هي هي نشات لانه في ظل الصراع على
السلطه ما بين البشير والترابي
البشير الترابي انشا هذه الحركه من
الكوادر الاسلاميه اللي كانت تقود الجهاد
ضد الحركه
حركه التحرير السوداني
جيش تحرير السودان
ايوه الحركه الشعبيه عند السودان في جنوب
هذه المجموعات وطبعا ما مجموعات عسكريه
بالمعنده لا مجهوده مجموعات جهاديه
مش ضباط انا سمعتها زي التقرير بتاع
الشنقيطي بيقول انه الضباط الاسلاميه ما
في حاجه اسمها الضباط الاسلاميين مشوا
عشان يعملوا الحرب اجوبات الاسلاميه للجيش
اسلم وقاعد في محله لكن المجاهدين المع
الترابي هم اللي انفصلوا بقياده
خليل ابراهيم ومشوا وعملوا حركه العدل
والمسافه حركه العدل والمساواه هي نشات
كجزء من الصراع على السلطه ما عنده اي
قضيه
يعني ما نبعت كسبب اساسي لدارفور لانه
الحركه
ظلت مع الترابي
في اسوا سنين العشريه الاولى اللي كانت
ترابي فيها متحكم في كل شيء كانوا مبسوطين
وسعيدين وما عندهم اي مشكله بتزورنا
الواجب على دامت السلطه في الخرطوم
بيفتكروها هم عندهم يستطيعون ان يفعلوا
بها ما
لكن عندما عندما حصلت المفاصل في الخرطوم
ظل نشات حركه العدل والمسوقه الجناح
العسكري لحركه الترابي لغات بها البشير
عسكريا في صراعه على السلطه
وقيادي في حركه تحرير السودان وايضا خاله
كان قيادي كذلك في حركه العدوى المساواه
في كتاب له خصص عن قضيه دارفور تكلم عن
حركه العدو والمساواه وذكر مثل ما تفضلت
بانها لم تكن قضيتها دارفوريه او معالجه
ازمه الاقليم وانها حتى لم تكن توافق على
المباحثات السلام التي كانت تعقد في عدد
من الدول في اثيوبيا واتفاق جوبا وايضا
الاجتماعات التي كانت في الدوحه ما بين
2004 و2006 و207 او 8
بحسب يقول كانت قضيتها مشروع الحركه ينادي
بتشكيل حكومه قوميا انتقاليه قائمه على
تداول الاقليمي وفق التقسيمات الحركه وانا
ارتادت منابر حصريه التوصيف في اقليم
دارفور لان لتكسب من خلالها يعني انها
قضيه دارفور ولكن بالاساس هي الاسقاط
حكومه
البشير في ذلك الوقت صحيح لا هذا صحيح
بالتاكيد وهذا الكلام اللي انا قلته من
انه حركه
حركه العدل والمساواه هي الجناح العسكري
لحزب الثاني في ظل صراعه مع على السلطه مع
البشير ولكنها طبعا يعني بشكل معروف انه
لا يمكن ان تعلن عن نفسها تقول انا
اصارع على السلطه يعني والا اذا انكشف
امرها للناس يعني ولكن جاء تبنيها لقضائد
ارفور وقضايا العدل والمساواه من باب
تجميل الصوره واعطاء التبرير الذي
تحتاجه
حركه تعمل تحمل السلاح
وتحتاج لمشروعيه اخلاقيه
لحمل السلاح
مع انه هي حملها للسلاح لم يكن له اي
مشروعيه اخلاقيه الا في ظل الصراع على
السلطه
ولذلك يعني هي وعيها بهذا الامر على تتبنى
اسم
لامع العدل والمساواه لا احد يرفض العدل
ولا احد يرفض المساواه
وايضانا قضايا دارفور من باب المنصه لانه
هم اشعلوا الحرب في دارفور يعني المسرح
الحرب كان في دارفور لا يمكن ان تشعل
الحرب ارضها بدون الحديث عن قضايا دارفور
لذلك تبنوا من باب الاعلام الكاذب تبنداني
من باب تجميل الوجه وتجميل الصوره حتى
يبدو عمل لا اخلاقي اخلاقيه طيب استاذ
بالنسبه للعناصر
تنضمت لحركه العدوى والمساواه هل كانوا
فقط من اقليم دارفور اما كانت من اقاليم
متنوعه مختلفه وكم يعني يقدر عددهم في
الحقيقه
الغالبيه العظمى
هي من دارفور وليست من دارفور وحاسب هي من
قبيله واحده هي قبيله الزغاوه ومسيطر
عليها من طن واحد من بطون هذه القبيله هي
البطن الذي ينتمي اليه قاده حركه العدل
والماء ده الطبيعه القبليه والعشائريه
لهذه الحركه لكنها ايضا
ضم لها انضم لها في على مستوى القياده
افراد من جميع اقاليم السودان المختلفه
اكتسبت مجموعات يعني لاسباب يعني تتباين
بحسب الناس عن هناك من يريد ان ان يجد
موطا قدم هناك من يريد سماسره السياسه
كثيرين في الدنيا هناك من
مفاجاؤوا جاؤوا لانه شعروا بالحاجه يعني
الحركه نفسها كانت عايزه زي ما تعكس ان
تغاتل من اجل دارفور عايزه تعكس وجهي غير
عشائري
فعايز لها واجهات
يجملوه صورتها هي كلها
يعني عمليات تجميليه
فانضم اليها مجموعات افراد على على
واجهات القياديه
ينتموا الى اقاليم مختلفه ينتموا الى
انتماءات فكريه مختلفه غير
الاسلاميين يعني لكن تبقى هويتها
الاسلاميه وهويتها العشائريه هي الاغلب
فضلت لا تقتصر على القبائل العربيه هي
متنوعه
العادي والمساواه لا انا لم اقول ذلك انا
قلت انه العدل والمساواه هي تنتمي
غالبيتها غالبيه الحرب جنودها على
قياداتها هي تنتمي الى قبيله الزغاوه
في قبيله الزغاوه تنتمي يسيطر عليها البطن
الذي ينتمي اليه غائب الحركه
الغالبيه الحركه وهويه الحقيقيه
والاسلاميين
ولكنها لتجمل صورتها اكتذبت الى واجهاتها
القياديه افراد من جميع انحاء
وافراد اخرين لا ينتمون الى الاسلاميين
يعني جابت ناس علمانيين جابت ناس من قبائل
اخرى جابت ناس من شمال السودان جابت ناس
من وسط السودان افراد زيدي ليه لانها
عايزه تعكس وجه قومي مش وجهي قبلي عشائري
ولهذا السبب هي كانت ترفض اي صفقات او
حلول لحل ازمه قضيه دارفور يعني كان للناس
عندهم اشكاليات تعويضات ماليه وتعويضات
للاسر او اعاده النازحين وما الى ذلك
فكانت دائما ترفض مثل هذا الطرح
لانها ترفع شعار ابعد من دارفور بالضبط هي
كانت هي كانت
هدفها الاكبر والاسمى هو حيازه السلطه في
الخرطوم
ولصالح حركه الترابي لذلك
هم هم تلاميذ مخلصين لزعيم الحركه
وانحازوا له في ذلك الصراع على السلطه
ولذلك يعني
كان
كان همها هم الصراع على السلطه ولم يكن
دارفور من اولوياتها الغصوه او العليا
اليوم الع
دو يعني الحكومه الحاليه او النظام الحالي
في السودان الحالي الان رئيسها
من اخيه الذي قتل في المعارك
وجبريل ابراهيم وانه
عندها عدد من الوزراء جاؤوا كنتيجه لما
يسمى باتفاقيه جوبا التي
ابرمت
في العام 2020 نفتكر
واللي
جاءوا فعندها قسم من السلطه هي ما زالت
ينتمت تامرت مع البرهان للانقلاب على
حكومه حمدوق مع بقيه مع حركه من ناوي ايضا
تامر مع مع البرهان
للاطاحه بحكومه حمدوق وطاحوا بها واحتكروا
السلطه لمده سنتين او يزيد قليلا
بعد الانقلاب وما الى ان دخلت البلاد في
هذه الازمه الحاليه وهم ما زالوا هناك
احنا
تيار ترابي هو يعني يحتل موقع متنفذ في
المشهد السياسي الحالي او الحكومه الحاليه
في السودان عن طريق حركه العدل المساواه
يستطيع ان نقول ذلك طيب اسمح لي
دكتور انه احنا نتوقف هنا في الجزء الاول
من حلقتنا ونكمل في الجزء الثاني حديثنا
عن
الجنجويد او قوات الجنجويد والملابسات
التي ارتبطت بهذه القوات وهي ايضا مرتبطه
في اشياءنا
يعطيك الف عافيه يا دكتور شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]